this is a production of Cornell
University
so next year I'm gonna be talking a
little bit more about my efforts to
breed for disease resistance in
Northeast adapted tomato but today I'm
going to be talking about something a
little bit different I'm going to be
talking about an experiment that I did
to evaluate some of our insect resistant
tomato lines against this guy right here
the Western flower trim so the Western
flower thrip causes damage to tomato
both directly and indirectly and
directly it's done by sucking out cell
contents and by inserting eggs into the
epidermis of the leaf and stem tissue
and that's called ova position it also
causes indirect damage by transmitting
viruses such as the tomato spotted wilt
virus seen there and traditionally that
system is managed by insecticides but
there could be an alternative so a so
sugars are foliar secondary metabolites
they're insect resistant metabolites and
they're accumulated in particularly high
quantities by wild species in Solanaceae
so here we see some type four trichomes
with droplets full of acyl sugars and
the acyl sugar phenotype of a plant is
defined by two primary parameters so the
first one is the aggregate amount of all
of the different types of basil sugar
and the second is the chemo type or the
different structures or chemical
components that make up the a so sugars
and the kibo type can be quite diverse
in tomato
there could be a monosaccharide or a
disaccharide sugar base there can be
three to four attached fatty acids and
those fatty acids can be attached in
different spatial orientations they
could be of different lights and they
can be branched differently luckily for
me Martha and John had recently created
a number of inbred tomato lines that
varied both the amount and chemo type in
tomato which allowed me to test a few
hypotheses so I wanted to know do fully
Reysol sugars impact thrips over
position rates and tosco virus
inoculation rates if so is there
variation for that insect resistance
phenotype just as there's variation for
the acyl Sugar plant phenotype and can
some of that variation be attributed to
either the amount of a so sugar or the
chemo type of the a so sugars or some
combination of both
so to do that I did an insect choice
assay so a Western flower thrip was
exposed to to leaf disks and these leaf
disks were from the same leaf from the
same plant treated identically in every
way except that one was washed with
water and that temporarily removes the
foliar exudates by about 75% allowing me
to test presence/absence of a slow
sugars in a separate dimension looking
at differences among genotypes we have
celebrity and m82 which were included in
the experiment these are commercial
tomato controls they accumulate only
trace Asil sugars we have C 0 or 7 1 or
2 6 which is our acyl sugar benchmark
breeding line it accumulates about 15%
the level of acyl sugar of Solanum
Pinelli i la 7 1 6 we also have lines
that have a slow sugar level QTL that
modified the amount of acyl sugar we
have lines that modify but the Kimo type
of acyl sugars and importantly we have a
fatty acid 5 line and this line has a
Kimo type modulating QTL but it also has
a pleiotropic interaction with the acyl
sugar level that causes it to have a
level that's very low like celebrity and
m82 which gives us a very powerful and
closely related control to the rest of
the material here so here I am setting
up the the insect galleries the 2 leaves
Washington unwashed they're set in auger
so that the insect can only interact
with one side of the leaf disk then 10
female flower thrips 10 female Western
flower trees are inserted into the
center of the gallery and they're
allowed to feed and oviposit for about
24 hours after which point the leaf is
stained with McBride's solution d
stained with lactic acid and then under
the microscope I can count the eggs so
here's 1 & 2 in this nice leaf disc and
what we find is that the probability
that a leaf or that a that a Western
flower thrip oviposit s' into the washed
leaf disk which is reduced in a so sugar
as opposed to the probability that it
oviposit s' into the unwashed acyl sugar
intact leaf disk is significantly
different for every single line in my
experiment and so it shows the effect of
removal of foliar accidents at least
temporarily but importantly the
magnitude of that difference there
across genotypes and so if I'm to take
this plot and just kind of clean it up a
little bit by just looking at the
unwashed leaf disks side by side by
genotype we see that same distribution
but it's more clear to see that some of
lines like fatty acid 7 and a so sugar
6/10 did particularly well in reducing
the probability of over position
especially when considered or when
compared to be commercial tomato
controls and are closely related
breeding line which has low pixel sugar
level the fatty acid 5 line now we did
the same thing for Tosca virus
inoculation except this time the trips
were infected with tswv and then we did
eliza at the end too to count the
incidence of infection and we see a very
similar trend where again fatty acid 7
and the acyl sugar 610 line are among
the best performing lines but
importantly you see quite a bit of
additional variation in this experiment
as opposed to this experiment and part
of that is due to differences in the
number of replicates but I also
hypothesize that the the amount of
inputs that go into the decision behind
OVA position may be greater than 4
tosspot virus or excuse me then for
feeding because there are real
ramifications for the survival of your
offspring in deciding where to put your
eggs as opposed to where to just try and
feed it at a spot so you know like that
spot you can just move on to the next
spot and I think that maybe there might
be a connection between the difference
in the levity of those decisions and a
variation seen in these experiments we
also see that among the high acyl sugar
producing lines there's still quite a
bit of variation in insect response and
so you could ask the question well is
that variation due to the acyl sugar
level or due to changes in a so sugar
chemo type and I should remind you that
these lines here although they have QTL
that modified chemo type there's also
pleiotropic interactions between those
QTL and the acyl sugar level or amount
phenotype which allows us to do a
logistic regression for the probability
of ova position against the
Oh sugar level of a line and what we see
is that as the acyl sugar level
increases for a line the probability
that a trip lays its egg in the unwashed
leaf so that's the leaf with the acyl
sugar in it goes down significantly
almost to zero and the opposite is true
for the wash link disc we see a very
similar trend for tswv inoculate
inoculation where the probability of
infection in the unwashed leafiest drops
from about 60% again to about one to two
percent but you could also ask the
question well what about the chemo we
have all these fatty acids that we've
measured some of which are correlated
some of which are negatively correlated
or uncorrelated do any of these have an
impact in insect damaging behaviors and
unfortunately because of the
aforementioned pleiotropic interactions
between the QTL there's no way to
experimentally isolate the changes in
chemo type but we can still build a
model to try and make some educated
guesses as to what might be going on in
the background and that's exactly what
I've done here so I used minimum AIC
variables are minimum AIC model
selection criteria and a Bayesian
statistical framework called first bias
reduced maximum likelihood estimation -
and - and I also used am a forward step
wise variable selection to identify my
predictors from a pool of predictors
that best described over position rates
and that pool of predictors included the
overall aggregate amount of a so sugar
the amount of acyl sucrose verses days
of glucose and the amount of all of the
different individual quantitative fatty
acids and when you do that interestingly
it doesn't give you a model that shows a
so sugar level or amount but it gives
you a model that shows two of the
individual fatty acid predictors as most
explanatory so that's a straight chain
c12 molecule and I so branched a four
carbon molecule for tswv inoculation we
again find that a fatty acid is most
explanatory and that fatty acid is the
straight chain ten carbon molecule which
is highly correlated to the twelve
carbon molecule seeing as the
as the most significant variable in the
first model so in essence these models
are showing fairly similar things and so
what have we learned well we learned
that there are differences among lines
or insects over position and
transmission we learned that in some
cases lions do particularly well at
reducing the incidence of tomato spotted
wilt virus or over position we learned
that some of the variation among these
lines can be attributable to the amount
of a so sugar that a lion has but we can
do a better job of describing and
possibly predicting the insect response
by including chemo type or the amounts
of particular chemo types and we can use
that information to guide our breeding
efforts to produce insect resistant a so
sugar lines for the field and with that
I'd like to thank dr. Suh they've been
Mahmood and dr. Diane Ullman at UC Davis
or my old bosses they helped a lot with
the design and implementation of this
experiment like to thank Tom Chapel at
Texas A&M for independently replicating
my model using sass and I'd like to
thank the much the muchly lab for
supporting me and for showing me how to
do the chemical analysis in tomato all
right thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions for tailor mark if you
don't give him a choice or not you don't
give him a choice so I did I did a
background experiment where I gave them
two leaf disks with what was that were
both unwashed so they were as dis and
they were of tomatoes so they don't
produce a whole lot of hazel sugar and
in that case the split was 50/50 for OVA
position they didn't oviposit into it
does that answer your question
that was on Celebrity yeah yeah I didn't
test that I was just more testing for
aggregation preference so if like one
was saying hey come over here this leaf
is better and then there was basically
in effect for one of the least spatially
as opposed to do they sow sugar so I
didn't test that specifically rain just
completely it does it knocks it out by
about 75% of the answer sugars come back
so you can see here actually something
that you can't see in this case because
this is a binary random variable here we
have two binary random variables where
both leaves can be infected
both uninfected or one or the other and
you see actually that the difference is
that they trend together and so what
this means to me is we actually let them
feed for too long so we let them feed
for 24 hours and what it looks like is
for a period of time
the washed leaves were more attractive
but then the acyl Sugar's came back and
then you see that train again with a so
sugar levels which if they were
completely removed permanently you
wouldn't see that would just be a flat
line on top yes how was the reply it
sprinkle it was with a Nalgene bottle
the tip was cut off so it was wider and
why was that done just did a little
sprinkle water
Oh cuz you have you have to be fairly
vigorous to knock the ASA Sugar's off
exactly
so actually a rain unless you're talking
about tropical storm it's not for to be
polluting it yeah it's the power any
other questions
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu